bueno un discurso dentro de las claves
de lo esperado con muchas referencias
históricas también reconocimiento a los
gobiernos pasados en los que ha habido
alguna recopilación de las medidas que
ya se habían anunciado como por ejemplo
esa de la creación de medio millón de
empleos de 3700 millones de dólares en
programas especiales en chile pero
también nuevos anuncios como puede ser
el hecho de que se enviará al congreso
una ley para por ejemplo la eutanasia se
incrementarán el monto de las pensiones
y todas las personas en chile todos los
adultos tendrán una pensión básica de
250 mil pesos muy por encima de la
actual que se encuentra en torno a las
140 y 165 mil 180 mil pesos y también
reformas al sistema de salud se creará
un fondo universal de salud también es
una de las demandas claves que había
solicitado la ciudadanía desde hace
mucho tiempo vemos entonces algunas
medidas concretas que van en la línea de
las demandas sociales de la revuelta en
chile y de la ciudadanía en general
un discurso en el que también ha habido
muchas referencias al estallido al
proceso constitucional también al hecho
de que en chile protestante se puede
acabar pagando en algunos casos con la
muerte ha mencionado algunas de las
personas fallecidas durante el estallido
social y también ha dicho que llevaran a
cabo programas de reparación y no
repetición de las violaciones de los
derechos humanos
eso es más o menos algunos de los
aspectos más destacados de este gabriel
boric que ha señalado también como lo
hacía su antecesor el presidente
sebastián piñera que chile unido
trabajando unidos respetando las
diferencias saca su versión su mejor
versión eso sonaba mucho a la
administración de piñera y también que
ha hecho una ha señalado en varias
ocasiones que no partimos de cero a
hechos reconocimientos a gobiernos
anteriores como el gobierno de michelle
bachelet o de ricardo lagos- de
anteriores gobiernos lo que también
marca un tono distinto a la el boliche
el diputado que fue muy crítico en su
momento con algunos de estos gobiernos